Israeli and Lebanese leaders have signed
a U.S brokered deal that for the first
time lays out their Maritime Border in
the Mediterranean Sea it enables both
countries to conduct offshore
exploration for gas and oil the
agreement comes after months of indirect
talks that also ended a decades-long
border conflict two neighbors have no
official relations and are technically
at War Israel's prime minister yair
dapid called the agreement a diplomatic
achievement
discussions have been taking place since
2020 various Border Lines have been
proposed now the newly agreed upon
Maritime border will be known as line 23
. Connor prospective gas field will go
to Lebanon it extends Southward across
line 23 so Israel will share some of the
or the revenue
karish will remain within Israel's
Waters where the extraction of gas has
already started
bonus Smith is at the Israeli Lebanon
boundary in Northern Israel so how's
this being portrayed in Israel
Sami is getting a lot of play here in
Israel the documents were actually
finally handed over about 20 minutes ago
the Lebanese Village of nakura just on
the other side of the Border here with
Israel we understand that in fact the
Lebanese and Israeli delegates were in
the same room along with representatives
from the UN and U.S those documents
exchange formally recognizing the
borders between both countries Israel is
expected to make a press statement very
shortly it'll be carried on all the main
bulletins here in Israel because as far
as Israel's prime minister yahila Pete
is concerned this is a significant
diplomatic Victory as well as the
success he says for Israel's security
it's really after Decades of hostility
between the two countries really as far
as Israel is concerned essentially a
recognition by Lebanon of Israel's
existence they don't formally recognize
each countries but the fact of the
Lebanese signing this agreement shows
says Israel that as International
recognition in the uh witnessed by uh
France the U.S and the United Nations it
comes good timing as well for the Isle
of Pete because there are elections here
next week in Israel security always
plays well for anybody uh of any Israeli
Prime Minister to show that tough on
security and successful diplomatically
yeah lapid will hope this plays into uh
the election next week which is going to
be very very tight
all right thanks so much Bernadette
meanwhile the Lebanese government has
awarded a French oil firm temporary
control of an offshore gas block the
foreign minister was optimistic about
the agreement in an exclusive interview
with Al Jazeera
total energies and its Partners must
start work in the areas agreed upon with
the Lebanese government namely block
number nine in the Kana field it takes
time to extract gas if it's there and
the Lebanese people have great hope that
their country will become a gas
producing country
has more from the Lebanon Israel
boundary in southern Lebanon
there is no doubt for Lebanon it is
about the economy the economy has all
but collapsed this country is needs
really revenues and they're hoping that
they can begin exploring Lebanon is
still not a gas producing country in
fact International companies had so far
refused to begin exploration until a
maritime border agreement has been
signed Lebanon has really been pragmatic
about this whole process even Hezbollah
the iranian-backed group which really
has political and military power in this
country it took a step back it said that
it was up to the government to negotiate
this agreement and it would stand by any
decision taken by the government in the
past the group acted differently the
active group used to take this decisions
outside the outside the state so for
Lebanon yes this is about the economy
for Israel it is about security they
want guarantees in order to start
production and sending gas to Europe and
this is why really we saw the Americans
as well well as Europeans France France
also played a role here A minor role yes
but a role nevertheless to try to get
this agreement done because Europe needs
gas no doubt the Eastern Mediterranean
is not going to replace the supplies
from Russia but Europe seems to want to
diversify its sources of gas so all the
three sides you know a vested interest
in this what people what they're all
calling really a historic and landmark
agreement but they're also insisting at
least Lebanon that this has nothing to
do with normalization and this is not a
peace treaty and this is why we're not
seeing any Fanfare around the signing
ceremony it is taking place behind
closed doors and the agreement is being
signed in separate documents by the
different delegations